you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens what's up everybody
welcome back to e3 2016 on the game spot
co-op stage brought to you by lego star
wars the force awakens I'm one of your
host some kind of funny Greg Miller
alongside kinda funny zone call Moriarty
hello Greg kind of funny zone Tim yetis
lets him host key spot comes Chris
waters yeah hello how are you I'm
delighted now I've assembled this panel
of experts to decide once and for all
the best conference of III dunno just
shout out and become a segment early got
it will go through hendo treehouse I
assume we're all on the page PlayStation
yes yeah I think it's pretty is Lee yeah
that said this is what I said yesterday
yeah Microsoft can't catch a break yeah
right the example I use Xbox one selling
very well ps4 selling meteoric Lee so no
one cares that xbox one is something
very well Xbox one has a great
conference that Sony has goes last as a
better conference now no one talks about
how I xbox had a great right you wanna
be very clear both worse party first
both first party is very strong but Sony
clearly the winner five exclusives boom
boom boom boom boom right in the
beginning very little talking very
little fanfare just showing the games
what we were talking about why
playstation saying is that she clearly
at the library it's all these different
things but for part of it Chris is the
fact that it was the exact opposite of
all the conferences we hated it was
direct they hit you with the trailers
boom boom boom like you're saying and
then I mean let's not discount the
orchestra playing the presentation of
the whole thing from the set to the
orchestra all of that stuff was it was
about focusing it on the giant screen
here's a game here's something that's
gonna happen and they're gonna all them
you everything they're accompanied what
they were showing us right not what they
were telling us I think that's really
important and I think you were the one
who pointed out today while we were
talking or maybe it was Danny but i'll
give you credit with your American is
the fact that the curtains only open for
Hideo Kojima oh my goodness were closed
walked out in front of him a lot but
they only open to reveal the potato
kajima and that yeah that and everything
drew your attention up I mean that was
like that was a regal
entrance yeah I mean if this isn't
minting this guy as game royalty I don't
know what is like yeah he's already
there and they see them continue to
treat him that way I'm for it I mean the
dude is far from flawless but like to
have that kind of focus on a creator
like that like a rock star yeah awesome
no I think it's cool I think it's cool
that it gives it gives people for him to
be in that position it allows other
people to one day be in that position
you know you got to create it and you
gotta like be heist about stuff and be
excited on stuff or else no one else
will be and putting the spotlight on the
game creator as well like you know I
think Sean did a great job of emceeing
the event yeah but having creators out
there and Twilight um in thriving I
think that's great yeah I flies in the
face of what you were saying about some
of our shows about how you don't want
games getting announcements are not
within an 18-month window and even
that's stretching it yeah but I do i do
I think we might lose sight of the fact
that the okajima came out and said I'm
back and it really was his first real
public expect up here at since then
right The Game Awards didn't happen for
him and based on that you can imagine
that any a sextant it happened for him
because then a week you know at the end
of the PSX week they have the video
that's kind of awkward them and they and
they also ended with Paragon and sub a
PSX adapt as far as hell the I mean I
have two things say hey like I think the
Christmas point I think it's right like
I like the showcase the people that
create games we just had David cage on
before another game creator that's well
known that's the head of his studio and
this goes way back to the heritage of
why people left attard and found
activision the entire idea of like
founding a company to showcase games
this was also ea's charge in the 80s the
book people David Crane his face on a
box David cranes a boy and his blob you
know I mean so this goes way back to the
heritage of of that and I think it's
important that we do that because these
people are artists in their creators but
I don't think they would have materially
benefited or lost anything by not having
kochi mad that Congress they didn't need
him there sure and they still wouldn't
one without him there didn't win because
he was there and that game I mean anyone
who thinks that games coming before 2019
at the earliest is fooling themselves
and there's a lot of delusion around
that I think on the internet right now
but I give him the time he needs yeah
but you didn't you know I i do believe
like we said before it but that's their
really did it last year the 6 12 and 18
months salvo anything after 18 months I
don't want to see it i don't care if it
exists i don't want to know about it and
so it's cool to see Kojima's
you know game in the name and then you
got Norman Reedus back and all this guy
stuffs awesome kojima is a hero but we
don't need it you know you you let off
with these five great exclusives and
let's focus on those things they're
still riding it was still riding that
excitement train of him he's out now
he's free and here is i like it i think
that the i agree with what you're saying
generally but i do think that one or two
announcements that are this is a
far-flung thing this is why you need to
be excited for the future i think that's
a great thing where and yeah people
gonna be asking where is it every single
time but that's fun it's fun to
speculate and be like where is it where
is it gonna be a PSX is it gonna be an
FC three is it gonna be at TGS like I
like those questions without that we
always know what's gonna be there unless
it's a total surprise there's no fun in
that I mean I like that the surprise
angle I me because a lot of people are
being like well you know a colony being
hypocritical because you're crazy Sony
for announcing all these games are
showing these games in there we don't
know the release dates I'm like dollars
to donuts I bet you those are all 20 17
games so they showed you know got god of
war Detroit become human I probably both
2017 games i sverige detroit could slip
that's funny cuz i predicted it my to be
out this at fall yeah sure thing with
David cage one of them could slip but I
think but I think in terms of managing
the portfolio my instinct tells me that
they don't want to put dates on anything
because of what happens sure when you do
that and that happened with uncharted
and it happened with all right I mean
horizon it happens with almost
everything they denounced the last
guardian wait have you seen a date on
that was a really huge deal but I think
the intent behind what they're doing is
in their internal portfolio see how
everything shakes out with our like
they're probably aiming for 2017 for
those three games and of two of them hit
which I think they will I think you can
see days gone first half got a war
second half you know are you gonna see
horizon in February so I think they
manage things really well I will say
though that there was I've been talking
to people about this in the more i think
about the sony converse the more i think
it's true that neo slot was probably at
the end yeah and they showing days gone
there was just weird when it was kind of
Ellery and weird as an end cap to the
entire conference interesting yes
because they could have shown a trailer
and in game play back-to-back which i've
done before yeah dan is the rest of the
egg I know and they and so they put that
at the end which I think was interesting
and Andrew house giving our interviewed
of Financial Times two days before e3 is
just a random interview saying like neo
is real or our new consoles realer will
not be t3 is super weird and I sit back
and I still think that it was the intent
was to have it there and I think that
now that they know that the console will
show underpowered you have to assume
that they're kind of scared now whether
or not they've already got better there
through the looking glass that's over
and they have to release it or not I
still say they take that thing back
inside and figure out what they gonna do
with it because the Scorpio rumored
specs are way more powerful than the
fear the ps4 port case rumored specs and
it's entering to look at the sony press
conference and what we liked about it
you know that it was game game game game
relentlessly and compared to Microsoft
which I mean that had a lot more of the
sort of dynamism that past conferences
have had you know they had platform talk
they talked about Xbox Live they talked
about their ID and Xbox they had indie
games had a significant showing I think
they like like this conspicuous lack of
many indie games on the PlayStation
stage was a big change this year yeah
for them so Microsoft press conference I
think still really strong I think
amazing i think my defense conference
was one of the best ones they've ever
done and i think that i am shocked to
sony beat them like i really am I didn't
seem like when we finished the Microsoft
one it was like wow party really yes
they did nail it and that's what Colin
saying is like this year's has been
great the conference's were great EA was
the only bad one-man Ubisoft had issues
but like the thing is Ubisoft had games
like Ubisoft when you look at it for
what they announced if you're someone
that's looking at gamespot later on in
the day just reading the announcements
sure they had a great conference if you
watched it it wasn't that good along you
know she had an hour off in a whole hour
I kind of would have been great but
overall when you look at the
conference's from a pure announcement
standpoint everything they were all
great except for yet so but Microsoft
and Sony I think we're really they
nailed the presentation and the
announcements and I think that's the
most important thing I didn't even get
better than Microsoft in terms of pacing
and then Sony did and you're making a
strong case here Tim for Microsoft
strength and I think one of the reasons
is I think there's more to chew on in
the coming weeks from Microsoft you have
more about their plan as a company in a
in a variety in their a variety of ways
in terms of their internal development
their consoles their games sony with
their laser focus on games was high
impact yeah and you know the trailers
you're gonna want to rewatch them and
you are gonna want to line up the
release day
but once you've done that you know aside
from PSV are there's not a whole lot to
talk about Microsoft has a lot more to
sort of all right now I'm like actually
thinking about it do I need that upgrade
or am I gonna wait or what does this
mean for why even bother yeah well our
system when there's a better system
coming next year yeah i also i think
it's a it's a good move on sony to go to
the games games games games games thing
because microsoft talking about all
their xbox live stuff i think that stuff
super important i think that's obviously
speaking to the fans but i think that's
what PSX is for you know kind of get
more into the nitty-gritty stuff like
that and it really makes you think like
I wonder in a couple years will
Microsoft be playing catch-up and do
something similar to then talk about the
more community-focused off and the stuff
that's not fun you know the stuff that's
not like headline worthy like quick
quickie but it's more like meaningful to
the players right right because this was
a very different conference from Sony
they don't do stuff like this talk about
something that sorry to interrupt em
don't worry yeah all right let's talk
about saying there's a through line for
a few concerts are conferences BR yet
PlayStation VR Ubisoft heavy are being
played on stage in Bethesda's you talked
about the first real mentions of Triple
A games being fully playable in VR how
did you guys think it was you know how
do you guys compare each sort of VR
showing within the conference's one
thing is with Ubisoft I'm impressed that
a company finally showed be are being
played on a stage and it's worked it
didn't have any tech fails didn't have
anything it didn't look fun or coal but
you know the guy Eagle flight looks fun
it just doesn't showcase well what's the
problem if it would have been great for
one goal it would have been great for
one thing and that's it but when it was
like oh you're playing a full match then
it's like wanna check Twitter now
because it is not this is not fun to
watch yeah it's not fun to watch it all
and I think the big problem is it was
really hard to understand what the game
is and what the characters acted up if
not characters people on stage are
actually doing how are they controlling
it oh boy purely steering what there's
and are they it's goin on just sit yeah
but I will give it to them that at least
it works because we've seen a PSX we've
seen all three three shows the VR just
doesn't work on stage so at least they
had that but sony's conference that's
how you sell units oh my god PSV are I
guarantee you because the last night
they're gonna sell way more than they
were good there was suddenly stuff you
do wanted to play it wasn't a demo it
was
a weird experience it was remember the
kitchen demo that's resident resident
evil 7 star wars Batman it's just Final
Fantasy they're really just like all
right what are the big things and what
are the biggest games that we can put on
this and they did yeah and these but
these are experiences not getting except
for no resident experiences but I mean I
think that that's experiences or what
are gonna sell this stuff you know and I
think that really a big part of the are
showing off to your friends it's like
look at this cool new thing I have it's
like back when in the old days when
color TVs were a novelty I think a lot
of people buying VR is going to do it to
be the cool kid how people come over and
experience these things and they're
gonna want to experience Star Wars
sitting in an x-wing is awesome yes yeah
i agree i think i mean the christmas
point i think it was cool to see talk of
you know I wish doom was totally play
about know how it would render that in
VR without blowing everything up but it
soon being such a fantastic game I was
really exciting to see that kind of
stuff being shown in fought for running
NVR as exciting as well p SVR has a
great advantage with an install base and
I actually got an email from amazon now
confirming the release date has double
just cool so you know octobre 13 for
that um thanks for getting me one I
tried I could owe anybody while I'm by
myself I will get them from Sony I've
done an airplane nice you didn't help me
at all I tried we're gonna get them I'm
sure we're gonna get them uh but to me
like it also shows the marketing issues
that VR is gonna have BR I's significant
significant marketing issues indeed back
to Tim's point about but and really both
everyone's point about Microsoft showing
3 consoles basically also shows a
marketing problem as well and I wonder
if Sony was unintentionally like one of
the pieces of blowback from not showing
neil was being able to sit back and say
well how's Microsoft going to handle
this now because you have your console
you have your new console your new like
slim yeah and you have the really new
console and you can sit back and watch
out like what the tea leaves kind of
tell you about how to handle that
because you know dollars to donuts sure
as [ __ ] they're gonna have to deal with
this problem as well with three
different platforms yeah 4p Coweta but
three with that will release the slim
ps4 probably I thought I was going to be
here or a slimmer a cheaper ps4 and then
they have PS 4.5 so I think these issues
are you a paramount from a marketing
standpoint and also maybe suggest that
these are unforced errors that these
companies are making releasing things
that people don't really want and I want
to see if that's true as well well I
mean it's just the you know the
two cities with PlayStation neo and now
project Scorpio that Scorpio kept a lid
on it long enough to give me the Polish
presentation and have a bunch of
developers be like we want to give you
better experiences we want to give you
better games this allows it disallows it
we're Sony leaked it all out and it was
just like it's barely butter it's just
for for kids only for vrrrr I never got
on that about it and now it is the same
thing where whether you're coming up
from below or from up high you're going
to get back to that midpoint of but what
the hell why do I need this and that's
why I think that Scorpio has an
advantage because the way that they're
positioning this and they might not know
internally yet Microsoft even might not
even know internally what they're gonna
do with this machine it seems powerful
enough that it could be a new machine
like an entirely and they're talking
about like how its backwards compatible
and all those kinds of things that is
the problem with sony and that's why
everyone's like well Colin why are you
so mad at Sony for PS 4.5 I do you think
Scorpio is a good idea i'll make because
scorpio seems like it's a new console
and they're just i'm saying it yet and
when you go back in time and you realize
microsoft released xbox in the fall 2001
and then in the fall of two thousand
five four years later they release xbox
360 well you see already a precedent
being set for a new console that's
backwards compatible yeah sure so like I
feel like you I feel like with Scorpio
they might be eyeing like like aaron
greenberg told us a generation lyst kind
of approach to gaming and Sony a7 is
taking a more iterative approach without
being modular with a machine that's not
that much powerful and they're selling
its being like well don't worry about
it's not that much more powerful and
that's not going to sell the consoles
that's why I think Sony is [ __ ] up
and that's why I think Scorpio seems
like it's more on the right path but
what's really interesting to me is that
and what you know I don't know the exact
leaked specs of the the ps4 neo but the
xbox one s is more powerful has the 4k
stuff and it has the HDR and listen to
that it sounds like those are you more
comfortable than even the Scorpio it's
possible I think that's an even bigger
problem is that xbox has this thing an
even more powerful Xbox coming out in
two months yeah it's super interesting
to Microsoft's credit day and I said it
you know that's why I was surprised Sony
beat them they need to go on the
offensive and they took a shotgun just
shot it right in Sony's face now I don't
think that they realized that it was
gonna maybe some of those bolts might be
repelled back of them some of that grape
that grape shot might be repelled back
at them and it was but they needed to do
that and I thought that
yeah you know Patrick lepak like I said
yesterday friend of ours I can talk to
wrote really well that the Scorpio is an
admission by Microsoft that they lost
that like they're like they're saying
like we lost we lost ps4 and Xbox one is
over but now we're moving on to the next
thing and it's going to be the blinds
are gonna be blurred between that
console and I think that their
approaches smart I continue to think
that their hardware approach is smart
and by the way that s unit that's coming
out soon it's super sexy and super sleek
dad in here for an hour Greenberg it's
way smaller than your even letting on
and I think it'll be that looks about
the same size as the ps4 maybe even a
little smaller in some way so I think
it's kind of a really nice machine yeah
I just still feel like what I brought up
on the one of our shows the fact that
with playstation 4 neo I'm like oh sure
take my money I know of the hundreds of
hours I put into the PlayStation 4 i've
got my money's worth out of it it now to
have an xbox whether it's the next one
or an iterated or whatever the hell it
is it's for me now it's going to be no
prove it because i bought the xbox one
and i turn it on once every six months
to play an exclusive or whatever and
granted it's you know a luxury it could
be different but right now it is the
same thing of like why me to see what
this does Chris before I care well I
think project Scorpio is them starting
to prove it but like Holland said you
know they're seating that sort of ps4
xbox one yeah that'll there like uh you
know what what we really want your eyes
on is the future when we're gonna be the
Big Boss Hogg's on the scene yeah now
Tim mm-hmm why was EA a disappointment
we've talked about it in terms of what
they want this is better because but
what did EA T wrong well I think it's
easier now to look back on it now that
we know how the whole game was played
and where all the cards were on the
table because you know when it comes to
third party conferences there's always
the question of oh well they didn't show
this because they're gonna show it at
one of the big ones right so now that we
kind of know where everything kind of
fell I thought was really interesting
that the PlayStation conference was
really not third-party focused at all
yeah we didn't see titanfall we didn't
see call of duty we didn't see that or
we talked all day you're saying that we
didn't see battlefield and that's that's
interesting because you kind of expect
that you would have seen those things um
so then going back to EA it's especially
in comparison I feel like it's always
been hard to compare the third parties
to Microsoft or Sony we're back in the
day Nintendo but as the times went on
now the Patels does doing their thing
now that square dropped
and Konami dropped out where I Ubisoft
has step the game up it says duh just
created a new rule set of how you're
supposed to do that sure so EAS just
playing by their same rules they've been
playing by and they didn't have any wild
factors and I think that sony's
conference is a perfect example how to
do it games demos release dates
announcements surprises EA demos and the
names that are so far out that were
already announced I mean when Jade it
was good to see Jade Raymond's go on the
stage a really talented game creator
very celebrated game creator well known
for Assassin's Creed in other games yeah
working now at motive a new studio that
hasn't released a game yet telling you
exactly what you already know it was
just a complete waste of everyone's time
like I hate to put it like that but it's
like why my gosh package if this is
what's happening it's like well like we
already knew that like we already knew
that why you telling me like that like
like I don't already know that you know
everyone that's watching this conference
in knows what you're saying so like
where's the new stuff and I feel like EA
really shot itself in the foot because
they're so contingent on annual ization
which is fine i don't think there's any
problem with that at all and they make
great games they make really great games
actually they put their great publisher
but they just lack the fanfare way to
really that was the one convert arm like
you do not need to have a press
conference yeah yeah yeahs admit they
made that mistake last year with mass
effect they showed like looks get into
mass effect and then it was dev diary
dev diary concept our concept art this
year mass effect was a little more
robust but uh yeah that's a little war
alright that was I was floored that
that's all they said about mass effect
which indicates to me that game is in
some sort of trouble trouble like like
they should be further like oh yeah I
was shocked we didn't get a demo like
honestly that's the biggest thing is not
only were we not surprised by EA we
didn't even get what we thought we would
get I don't know we can slam-dunk did
yeah those slammed like those like mass
spec release still at least half mad
yeah like I don't know that like you
anyone would have been stupid walking
and being AG reporting at the release
date they're gonna show us 10 or 50
minutes of the game we're gonna explore
this you know this new galaxy a little
bit they show you nothing and I'm like
that's bad news I hate to tell you if
you think you're gonna fight that game
you know in the next calendar year I
would I would be confused unless their
approach is gonna be more like
Bethesda's with Vaughn for where
although it's two eggs the cats out of
the bag but fallout 4 where it's like in
June the game exists and in November
here it is you play it but they already
let the cat out of the bag that's why
but that's is so so [ __ ] good and
what they what they do and why they
actually showed a lot of restraint
except for the fact that they hid my
precious Wolfenstein game in some das
right as the the first thing they did
was to tease that Wolfenstein game a few
folks didn't see it it was a DOS prompt
it's right in there says the the new
Colossus was after you know the old
blood the new order they both had
release dates the new Colossus did not
so there's another wolfy time Scott
minute way but that's awesome she need a
how you do press conferences you put
those little things in there you have
those moments of ok you watch the press
conference you think it's cool and then
afterwards you like but you missed this
and that's awesome man yeah I think I
think I mean my biggest point in for
relief the entire what we stay open with
quake and I was like god damn it you
know like machine games is making quake
this has been especially with the rumors
you owe you wanted Wolfenstein you
thought that it was machine games on
quick right and I was like I'd when and
when 88 logo came up I was shocked
because I'm like wow it is scaled
significantly they just released a game
yeah quakes definitely to be a smaller
game the doom but but I was when I saw
that cool guy was like yes machine games
is still in play free think of you don't
like the teal and play yeah and so I
think next year we see even within two
and wolfenstein the new Colossus says
the big marquee games and maybe the
Elder Scrolls or something although I
doubt what did you guys think of it as
diverse Ubisoft let's talk about this
now because one of the things they both
did that you know other other
conferences have done in the past but
was focused on their big games and the
updates for them like the division
updates okay doom updates fallout 4
updates that stuff falls flat to me it's
the same thing where I think that
Bethesda ended and we were like all
right it was a solid show they had
information it didn't blow our hair back
it wasn't the fall at four conference it
wasn't this it was just them giving more
of these updates here whereas Ubisoft
was here is two hours of it and it was
like we're staying on paper Ubisoft was
great if you would cut it all out of
like you had a great ghost recon gemma
you got to see this just dance opens but
it was fine we were out of it real quick
south park yeah south park was amazing
and that's the thing is I think
comparatively Ubisoft for me at least
had more standout games in it but it's
so hard to stand out when I'm so
so lethargic and it just kept limping
and lumbering on and on and not stopping
yes tough to have yet you got a lot of
games to show you want to do you're like
it's the 30 years of the company fam I
thought that there was a lot of
earnestness and a lot of personality I
think I used to Tyler's a great host
yeah build it more like but yeah I think
that there is a trim the fat kind of
thing there you know like the division
is you know your best-selling New IP
ever but do you need that much on it you
know i mean i think that trimming that
up would have gone a long way but you
ride some really great games out of that
press conference right yeah i mean i
think the biggest thing was watchdogs
just in a sense that i was a little
confused why they even announced this
before e3 i guess maybe you know they
wanted to get it out there they want
people's eyes on it people were excited
about I'm looking forward to it similar
to the transition from assassin's creed
two assassins creed two I think if you
expect big things a big change as they
learn what people liked it didn't like
about the original but to just go on and
on and on about wash dogs too it's like
dude like cut just five but it is more
yeah like really by the B motion after
having the big reveal they have that
week leading up to it yeah 3 like
vignette videos about it's like I all
right get it knock it off ladies and
gentlemen what was your favorite press
conference to be 3 2016 let us know in
the comments below then share this video
dear friends and of course keep coming
back here to gamespot com or kinda funny
com for all the e3 happening
you